and now titties are a [ __ ] pandemic
because of Instagram I liked titties hey
dude
I liked titties titties were all gravy
man titties and midsections and [ __ ] and
thighs I was a red-blooded American male
Instagram made me hate titties bro how
you gonna make me hate teddies hey gonna
make me roll my eyes at Teddy's I was a
red-blooded American Merril up until an
Instagram now I'm a [ __ ] old man
robot Instagram hey go make me hate
titties so many titties dude
Halloween alright alright dude walking
into a party alright okay we get it
how much what how much money for me to
burst inside you what do you mean what
do you mean dude titties [ __ ] suck
dude you know I'm playing titties red
you don't claim their titties [ __ ]
rip and that crazy how dumb are guys
when they see titties you know how dumb
guys are this is how dumb guys are now
I'm gonna be straight-up honest with you
guys I don't really watch porn okay
your boy likes to use his mind I don't
really watch porn that much not saying I
don't but here's how dumb guys are when
you [ __ ] go to like whatever it is
pornhub or X videos or [ __ ] whatever
the hell it is I'm looking at it right
now
Wow okay you see all the videos you see
the thumbnails you pick the one you like
and you click on it and you look and you
start looking at Teddy's all right
then they show other thumbnails under
that video and the videos already
popping you're already where you are you
[ __ ] eat
[ __ ] you understand you're doing
what you're set out to do you start the
porns you watch the porns you [ __ ]
watching this [ __ ] and you're in it and
you got a [ __ ] thing going your your
uh your dicks starting a bracket kick
kack kack right
your dicks starting to [ __ ] breca you
know what I mean
you got your diving board all set up
your diving boards all set up dude now
it's illegal to have a diving board
nowadays in LA but your diving board is
all set up okay you got your caution
[ __ ] [ __ ] up it says caution
be careful dive in anyway so you're
watching the video this how dumb I am
this how dumb guys are you start looking
at the other thumbnails and you'll be
like oh but what about that one when
you're already doing what you want
that's how dumb guys are you're like ah
but what about the other one that chick
is cool about the way the positions are
another one looks pretty cool then you
click on that one and then you [ __ ]
start watching that one and then I got
more thumbnails and then you're watching
that one you know what I mean
you ever been having sex and you're like
I have it what else is going on huh
that's the goal you're watching porn and
you turn into a [ __ ] 90s comic yeah
so what else is going on in the world
let's click these other thumbnails
anyway what else going on in the news
click this one oh yeah anyway what else
is going on yeah what else is going on
in the news oh yeah cool I told you the
time I [ __ ] went into the Starbucks
and I had been watching porn earlier and
I open up the computer and I [ __ ] was
right at the part where the girl was
like oh yeah and I closed the [ __ ]
laptop dude that's the hottest part of
porn is when the girl is like so in it
and she's just you could I don't like
all the [ __ ] when the porn is like when
the girls like oh yeah give it to me
yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh you like that like
dude relax
his [ __ ] Riverdance stopped trying
the show this show
Hey hey sweetheart when you're having
sex and you're like and the girls oh
yeah yeah hey sweetheart are the credits
at the end of this whenever I would have
sex whenever I would do that when I used
to have sex and stuff like with like
chicks and I would do it and then and
then they'd be like oh yeah and I would
be like hey hey I would stop and I'd be
like who's producing this and she'd say
what and I'd say well this is ghost
Protocol and she said what do you mean
and I say well this is ghost Protocol
starring Tom Cruise with the way you're
acting she said I don't get it
and I'd say you're not part of [ __ ]
you're not part of I'm gonna do it real
man sex is real life so why [ __ ]
gloss it up bro
that's like that contour [ __ ] that
people wear you know whether you're a
guy or a girl you can't tour your face
man
what is this Kabuki theater hey who's
producing it when you see someone with
contour hey but who's producing this
what well you're in a movie what that
would be so hilarious to walk up to a
chick who had such hard contour on and
you just say hey who is producing what
he would say well we're on set this is
what do you mean this is Starbucks well
where are the cameras sweetheart what do
you mean what do you mean what I what do
I mean
you've got makeup for a movie on wow
dude you'd be canceled you'd be
cancelled she would pretend like she was
a victim and you'd be canceled